[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here
today i'm going to explain a japanese
post-apocalyptic action film called
attack on titan
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
over a hundred years ago gigantic
monstrous humanoids called the titans
suddenly appeared on the earth they fed
on any humans they could get their hands
on humans were not at the top of the
food chain anymore and soon their
population started to decrease
even after many civilizations were wiped
out mankind hadn't found a way to fight
the titans so instead they settled on
limiting their freedom to be safe the
surviving humans built massive
concentric walls taller than the titans
around an area to prevent invasion two
circular walls were constructed one
inside the other to ensure double
protection the outer space was called
the outer district and the inner was
called the inner district inside those
walls they could live a peaceful life
however the walls didn't guarantee
protection and even after a hundred
years people live in fear of the titans
the protagonist of the movie is a young
man named aaron yeager who lives in the
outer district he dreams of going beyond
the walls someday to explore the world
he frequently boasts about the seas and
oceans of the outer world to his friends
armin and mikasa
one day they decide to go to the border
and try climbing the wall to jump to the
other side when they get closer to the
border the group is shocked to see the
size of the wall
armin and mikasa are skeptical of the
idea claiming that the titans can still
be outside but aaron insists that it has
been a hundred years since anybody has
seen them and with no humans to feed on
they have probably died their
conversation is cut short when the
border patrol comes to arrest the group
for being too close to the wall aaron
infuriated by the police trying to
capture his friends starts fighting them
completely ignoring the fact that he can
be executed for this crime just then
captain suda approaches them and asks
the soldiers to back down he promises to
punish the group personally and sends
the soldiers away suda understands
aaron's desire for freedom but
criticizes his actions as childish he
then informs the group of a military
approach to explore beyond the walls he
explains that the government has sent
some soldiers outside to inspect the
situation so that aaron doesn't have to
put his life in danger all of a sudden a
loud explosion startles everyone an
earthquake follows it and the ground
begins to shake
the group retreats as the wall moves
aggressively
then a view of a massive titan on the
other side is seen
he lets out a loud screech and begins
kicking the wall the patrol officers
watch in fear unable to do anything to
stop the creature
the titan finally breaks the wall and
disappears into smoke everything goes
silent for a few seconds
then the people see many such creatures
enter the city the soldiers attack the
monsters with cannonballs which do them
little to no harm they seem to have
powerful regeneration properties as the
wounds caused by the cannons heal at a
great speed soon the titans reach the
soldiers and start devouring them one by
one one soldier even commits suicide
claiming that it is better than dying at
the hands of the monsters
everyone starts to run for their lives
as the titans destroy houses and grab as
many people as they can armin gets lost
in the crowd while aaron and mikasa run
towards the town church where people are
going to hide mikasa notices a little
child on the ground about to be stepped
on by the running crowd she goes to save
the child but gets separated from aaron
in the process aaron gets dragged inside
the church but the people close its
entrance right after not letting anyone
else get in aaron watches his dearest
friend from the church's window as she
is approached by a female titan with
terrifying teeth
mikasa knows that nothing can save her
now so she just lowers her head
accepting her fate
just then a loud explosion sends
everyone inside the church backward when
aaron looks outside again mikasa and the
titan are nowhere to be seen he runs
outside looking for mikasa only to come
across the ruins of the city that once
used to be his home when aaron turns
around he sees the monsters ripping the
church apart and devouring everyone
inside he wanders into the destroyed
city hopelessly
cut to two years later all survivors
from the previous titan attack have
moved to the inner district the military
is now planning to get the outer
district back
after the horde of refugees moving into
the inner district and abandonment of
the fertile farmland of the outer one
the scarcity of food starts killing
people if this continues everyone will
eventually die of starvation their only
option for survival is to take over the
outer district and repair the broken
wall the director of the military forces
is named kubal he gives the soldiers a
heartfelt speech and calls a girl named
hans on the stage she is the head expert
of the troops new weapon hans
demonstrates a new omnidirectional
mobility gear that she claims will help
them fight the titans but she attacks
her own people by accident
then we see aaron and armin in the
military crowd it turns out that both of
them survived the attack two years ago
and now have joined the military aaron
wants to avenge the titans for killing
the woman he loved mikasa captain suda
also survived the attack but has lost
his will to live he is now a food
distributor in the army and an alcoholic
the soldiers plan to invade the outer
district at night when the titans will
fall asleep they want to close the way
that the titan invaded the city so that
no new titans can enter then they can
kill the remaining ones and get their
district back
hans asks everyone to move forward
slowly and not make any noise as the
monsters are sensitive to sound the
entrance to the outside district opens
and the army drives out in military vans
as they move forward the captain
abruptly orders them to stop the
vehicles sensing a movement ahead the
soldiers slowly look around only to find
cows roaming in the city one of them
named hina hears a baby crying and
decides to investigate it putting her
life in danger aaron follows the girl
and the two end up inside a destroyed
building the cry becomes clearer as they
go further in suddenly a slimy liquid
falls onto hina the two look up and are
terrified to see a massive baby titan
eating a human the baby falls in front
of the two and starts to cry they run
away outside in fear the soldiers start
to panic because of the noise but the
captain orders them to keep quiet and
not attract any titans suddenly a
massive hand emerges out of nowhere and
grabs the captain the titans have awoken
now the soldiers are in great danger
aaron and hina run towards the group as
a massive monster follows them they
start running back to the vehicles but
commander kubal senses the danger and
runs away with the vehicle and the
weapons hans from inside the vehicle
asks the group to come to an abandoned
building nearby the soldiers run towards
the building but are surrounded by the
titans before they can escape they lose
all hope when all of a sudden a titan
killer and captain of the scout regiment
shikishima appears he uses a swinging
device to kill the titans midair by
striking the weak zone behind their neck
shikishima has a female partner as
skilled as him the killed titans fall to
the ground and evaporate aaron finally
gets a glimpse of shikishima's friend
and is beyond surprised to see that she
is mikasa mikisa however pays no
attention to her old friend and looks at
shikishima smiling at her the two then
go to the building followed by the
soldiers it turns out the commander
kubal has appointed shikishima to help
him with the mission shikishima saved
mikasa's life that day and even taught
her how to fight the titans since then
they have been working as partners
living in a world of titans mikisa has
learned the harsh reality of life and
doesn't want to associate with people
from her old life anymore later one of
the soldiers blames aaron for attracting
the titans earlier and putting
everyone's life in danger the two get
into a fight but are soon stopped by
mikasa shikishima asks aaron his name
and showcases his superiority by
bringing aaron to have a chat with him
in private aaron tells shikishima that
he wants to learn to kill the titans and
blames the monsters for trapping them
shikishima laughs at him claiming that
humans trapped themselves not the titans
they were too scared to fight and their
cowardice brought them where they are he
then provokes aaron by calling him a
coward when aaron denies being one
shikishima asks him to let go of his
fears and fight the titans for his
freedom aaron then goes looking for
mikasa and finds her playing a broken
piano he tries reuniting with her but
mikasa seems disinterested in his
efforts she says that she turned into a
different person when the baby she was
looking after died mikasa then reveals a
bite mark on her body showing what the
titan attack had done to her they are
interrupted by shikishima who feeds
mikasa an apple with his hand showing
his affection towards her a heartbroken
aaron runs outside and screams in agony
his only love who he thought he wanted
to avenge is no longer the person she
used to be just then hina approaches
aaron and comforts him the two return
inside the building and are talking as
another couple beside them makes out
hina gets emotional telling erin about
her daughter who is back in the inner
district she then tries to seduce aaron
and forces herself on him but they are
interrupted when a giant eye stares at
them through a window it suddenly drags
hina with its mouth not giving them much
time to think aaron watches helplessly
as his friend is eaten by the monster
many other titans approach the building
shikishima mikasa and the other soldiers
put on their gear and fight the titans
shikishima kills most of them along with
mikasa but many others are injured
because this is their first time
fighting the explosives are the only
asset that will help them get rid of the
titans in the long run so commander
cubal asks everyone to protect them
meanwhile the couple who were making out
earlier are attacked and the man dies in
the encounter the woman is devastated by
her lover's death and vows to avenge him
by killing the creature who killed him
then we see a person getting into the
vehicle with the explosives and driving
away the woman who had just lost her
lover plans to sacrifice herself and
jumps on the vehicle to light the
explosives she takes over the steering
wheel and drives towards the titan who
killed her lover as she crashes into the
titan the explosion blows up his legs
however the attack doesn't work because
the titan's legs grow back quickly the
only way to kill them is to strike their
weak spot aaron is still on top of the
building and hasn't helped others defeat
the titans yet he remembers shikishima's
words from earlier and uses the springs
to attack them he struggles at first but
manages to make his first kill with a
little guidance from shikishima however
he loses his balance right after and
flies directly into another titan's
mouth the titan bites off one of his
legs but aaron manages to save himself
by jumping onto the rooftop suddenly a
titan gets a hold of armon as he is
trying to run away the others try to
save him as the titan is about to eat
the guy aaron whimpers in pain but
doesn't stop trying to help his friend
he drags himself towards the edge of the
building and leaps into the monster's
mouth holding it open armin is about to
slide into the monster's throat but is
saved however aaron drops into the
titan's stomach in the process there he
lies in between several dead bodies one
of them being hina meanwhile mikasa and
the others are on a rooftop where armin
tells her about aaron's death mikusa
fails to hide her emotions and is
visibly sad to have heard the news
furious she launches at the titans and
kills every single one of them however
her fuel runs out midway making her fall
to the ground the titan who ate aaron
earlier approaches mikasa and is ready
to kill her but suddenly a hand emerges
out of the creature's mouth soon his
body blows up revealing another titan
inside of him the newly formed titan
fights his own kind and kills them one
by one the surviving soldiers watch in
awe as they realize the new titan is
actually aaron after killing everyone
the titan approaches the building
aggressively aaron seems to have
forgotten who he is and is killing
everyone in sight the soldiers retreat
in fear except for mikasa who calls
aaron's name but he doesn't stop and he
grabs her while looking at her he slowly
gains his memory back and begins to
recognize mikasa he then falls dead to
the ground and starts to evaporate like
the other titans mikusa slices his weak
spot open and the human errand emerges
from the creature to everyone's surprise
he has grown his leg back with the help
of the creature's regeneration powers
the last titan finally evaporates and
aaron slowly gains
consciousness subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and make
sure to watch the anime series attack on
titan which is way better than this
terrible movie
oh and leave a like to help the channel
out